Oh look at the trade,
right?
Trump is making a big deal about the trade deficits and he's launching,
terrorist is going to have this trade war that he's convinced that we could win.
And this is very misguided.
The trade deficits are not the problem.
They are the consequence of the problem.
The problem is that we have bad monetary policy,
bad fiscal policy,
too much regulation.
That's why we have a trade deficit,
because American industry is not productive enough.
We don't save enough.
We don't make the right capital investment.
That's because interest rates have been kept too low.
You know,
our tax code,
uh,
favors debt,
you know,
and we have a lot of regulations that make American businesses less competitive.
And so the result is that we import a lot of products rather than making them
ourselves.
And it's not because the other countries aren't fair or because they have
terrorists.
Terrorists are very low around the world.
I mean,
there's tariffs are not the problem.
And so if Trump is simply going to erect tariffs,
all that's going to do is tax the American public because the American public
has to pay the tariffs whenever they buy imported products.
So this is not going to,
I'm going to turn the economy around.
But you know,
and Trump is right.
He points out that,
well,
you know,
at one point in time America ran on terrorists,
which is true during the 19th century,
the government,
you know,
raise money pro permanently by terrorists.
But we didn't have an income tax,
you know.
And so this is the irony of it.
The reason we have an income tax today is because the populous politicians of
the day told the American voter,
if we can tax the rich with an income tax,
then we can get rid of terrorists that the average person is paying.
So the average person understood that terrorist costs them money.
And the politicians said,
let's get rid of these tariffs and let's just tax the rich.
And the income tax that was originally proposed really was a tax on the very
rich.
I mean,
even doctors and lawyers didn't pay it.
you had to be super rich before you pay the tax.
And then it was like,
you know,
1% to 4%.
So it was a small tax and it,
and it wasn't taken from your paycheck,
right?
I mean,
first of all,
if you,
if you got a paycheck,
he didn't pay the tax,
but we didn't have withholding until 1943 that was part of the,
the victory tax to pay for the Second World War.
But Americans were told let's tax the rich and you won't have to,
uh,
pay tariffs anymore.
Well,
the minute that the government got the nose under the tent,
right,
all of a sudden now the income tax affects everybody,
right?
People pay a lot more in income taxes today than they used to pay in terrorists.
But now,
now the president wants to bring the terrorists back on top of the income tax.
I mean,
if Trump wants to repeal the income tax and get rid of it entirely and then have
some terrorists,
I'd be okay with that.
But you can't do that unless you dramatically shrink the size of government,
which is the most important thing that Trump needs to do.
But what he's not doing,
he has to make the military smaller,
not bigger.
I mean,
he's talking about a space for us.
we can't even afford the air force navy marines that we got now.
We be around moving money for space force,
but we have to cut everything.
We got to cut entitlements,
right?
He's thing we should be the first people to have a space for us.
What are the Russians come up with a space for us?
No one's going to come up out of luck.
What does that even,
what did he do?
His space for us when we who we can fight in space.
Maybe we fight the Russians as bay.
Well,
why would we fight them in space?
Their doubt on earth.
Well,
maybe they want to fight in space.
It's more novel.
Yeah.
I don't think,
I don't think anybody wants to fight right now.
It'd be protected.
Right?
Yeah.
I,
I think we got that covered.
I think we've got a pretty good size military.
I don't think anyone's going to mess with us.
The problem is our economy,
so.